So far we've been making games that only
display one logical thing to the user.
But real games have lots of
different sorts of stuff to display.
There's the game world itself, but
you might also have menus, settings,
inventory screens, and so on.
You could accomplish this by putting
switch statements everywhere, but
there's a better way.
Libgdx provides a screen protocol and
an implementation of application
listener called game, which delegates
all the application listener callbacks
to an implementation of screen.
Then to change from
the game world to a menu,
you just have to call
set screen on your game.
Let's check it out.